welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Rick and Morty season 4
episode 4 just made whatever list mr.
jellybeans is on a whole lot longer
oh nothing needs to be getting longer
right now because claw and hoarder
special victims morning is smut I
enjoyed it but just so that I don't end
up on any lists it's it's it's much I
don't think there's any confusion over
this episode's commentary about dragons
being masturbatory escapism but there is
one mystery tucked away in the B plot
what the hell is that cat all about what
cryptic Horror Show did Rick and Jerry
see that shook them to their core and
will it matter in future episodes later
in this analysis we'll discuss this
episode with special guests let's
quickly dig into the dark secret of claw
and hoarder special victims Morty this
episode of explained warnings both for
spoilers and triggers like Jerry this
episode no person who's young or young
at heart should look too deeply into
this because memory wipes do not exist
in our world sadly ok as rick morty and
summer deal with flood dragons the be
story of this episode comes off a bit
tame on the surface until we learn what
it's really about jerry discovers a
talking cat voiced by matthew broderick
simply wants to be taken to Florida for
some partying and volleyball
but in the end Rick learns that all that
good timing is why scans the cat's mind
to learn the truth see the truth
Oh son of a [ __ ] Jerry don't want to
see no you do not Christ
Rick sends the cat away as he and Jerry
scream through psychotic breakdowns Rick
actually nearly shoots himself in the
mouth with any whites Jerry's memory so
that Jerry won't have to live with a
horrible knowledge of this cat's origin
then later in the post-credits scene the
cat encounters the dragon is there a
reason you can speak yeah
and I'm ashamed of it then speak of it
no more do you wish to eat maybe bond a
little yeah I could bond how long does
it take you to fly to Florida so
according to the writers of this episode
the mystery cat was a nod to animated
kids movies in which animals could talk
and it's never really explained the cat
subplot was an attempt to just have fun
the cat represents that voice in your
head in the writers room it's like
you're overthinking it just have fun
that came from like it was Disney movies
like Oliver and company or anything like
that like they never really explained
why the cats can talk the cat is here to
save Jerry from overthinking it yeah
sure but this is also the writers room
notorious for overthinking everything so
it wouldn't surprise me if there
actually was an answer to this cat
mystery but the writers are rightfully
holding off from revealing it and I
believe that this episode actually gave
us all the clues we need to piece
together the dis cat's awful awful path
clue number one the audio of the scan
that Rick and Jerry watched you listen
closely to that sound mixing you can
hear people screaming general sounds of
mayhem and then this
yes that was distinctly the sound of a
baby crying and he can hear it again in
the brief second that Jerry watches it
so this cat's past crimes must involve
children but kids aren't the only
vulnerable demographic this cat
victimized is told to us by Jerry in the
next clue so why are Jerry's parents
important here well remember the one
time we met them Leonard and Joyce back
in season one Jerry's biggest concern
about them was what to fear that they
were being exploited in a sexual
relationship with Jacob so keep that
mind in the gutter as we move on to clue
number three Florida my home state so
why Florida
whyever Florida could there be somebody
to the fact that Florida is a popular
state among elderly retirees or is it
just the fact that the state's known for
its reckless sex parties sex is
definitely on the cat's mind evidence by
clue number four did you know what a
peanutbutter gargoyle is know is that
dude it's when you take the chick put
her feet on a cathedral try to drop guys
just want to clarify are these real sex
positions because if they are how are
they gratifying to the male at all yeah
it's no mystery that this episode on the
whole is all about sexual deviants the
fact that the cat bonds with the dragon
the post-credits scene proves it and the
biggest clue stared at us and the
freaking face the whole time look at the
fur pattern on the cat's nose folks it's
in the shape of a dick and balls
literally on the nose and what's
interesting to me how the cat's crimes
made them vomit not too much of the dark
[ __ ] on this show induces vomiting but
there was one similarly unspeakably dark
moment that the show treated the same
exact way we found it inside a locked
box inside came jelly beans closet see
whether it's mr. jellybeans urging to go
with the flow or this cat urging us to
not ask questions and just have fun it
all sounds like the same flavor of bad
news folks so I think that like mr.
jellybeans this cat is a freaking rapist
maybe one that targets children in the
elderly this episode and the mr.
jellybean episode are the only two in
the series to visit fantasy inspired
realms and both realms are sexually
violent in the title this episode is a
panade to Law & Order SVU
a series specifically about sex crimes
maybe this
episode of we're good morning the
surprise rapist is a cat so maybe the
cat is the mr. jellybeans of his
dimension maybe he's mr. jellybeans
reincarnated that's why Rick didn't kill
it because he killed mr. jellybeans
before he sees that same dark evil soul
in this cat and how he wouldn't know
which body this sex demon would
reincarnate into next folks I don't like
talking about this stuff but it's real
and it's something that the Rick and
Morty writers have addressed before and
when they brought that mr. jellybeans
episode back in season 1 in the year
2014 the show was still pretty low
profile they probably felt a bit bolder
but the kind of jokes they could try to
get away with but the years have gone on
the show is felt that they kind of have
to avoid the subject matter as the
show's appeal and viewership has widened
into the mainstream that is until now
when they call it out in this episode
when Rick participates in a soul orgy
with this underage grand kids so is the
cat there to mask these sexually violent
undertones of this episode maybe maybe
not but if it is I would not be
surprised if the writers just brush it
off as a metaphor for overthinking
things and it looks as though this cat
could come back in this season's finale
probably gonna air sometime early 2020
based on Rick's line Jesus your dad's
been texting me this whole time he's at
an airport with a cat okay that that
sounds Wow
you know I better check on him big
season finale right there you know well
what is your Rick's planation for the
cats while we're talking about questions
and answers a reminder that new rock
stars has launched a new weekly Q&A
series the big question where you can
ask us your nerdy's questions will apply
whatever nerdy laws of physics we
remember from grade school to try to
answer it first episode is on the
channel now go check it out it's great
and we'll continue this discussion about
this episode of Rick and Morty with some
special guests after a brief message
from our sponsors
why do people still go to the post
office especially during the holidays
when everyone is trying to send gifts
and cards to a loved one or fruitcakes
to unloved ones anything you can do at
the post office you can do at stamps
calm stamps calm eliminates trips to the
post office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't get at the post
office here at new rockstars we've been
using stamps calm to ship rewards to our
patreon patrons and it's been super
helpful in a big time-saver keep an eye
out for that hot hot merch blazing up
your mailbox as patrons Sam sicom brings
all the services of the US Postal
Service right to your computer whether
you're a small office sending invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
or even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps.com can
a little with ease not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of expensive
postage meters stamps.com is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm don't
spend a minute of your holiday season at
the post office this year sign up for
stamps calm instead there's no risk with
my promo code Ricks planed you get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage in a digital
scale no long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Rick's plane that
stamps calm and or explained stamps calm
and never go to the post office again
this episode was also brought to you by
Hawthorne fellows don't you hate having
to buy cologne for yourself don't you
wish you could just wash your sheets
with man musk scents roll around in them
and wake up ready to get smelled by your
coworkers smelling good is important
that's why I love Hawthorne instead of
smelling a bunch of cents in a store
until they all smell the same and you
have brain damage Hawthorne has you take
a short quiz about your lifestyle and
preferences and then they send you to
scents one for work one for play they
offer this handy quiz that I loved
there's a scale for Bo that goes from
know Bo too painful Bo and to me all bo
is painful because the interior lining
of my nose has degraded this is smelling
cologne it's not anything else they also
have deodorant shampoo and body wash the
whole process is easy and convenient
best of all it's totally risk-free with
free shipping and free returns check out
Hawthorne at Hawthorne and Co that's
Hawthorne with an E and use my promo
code Ric to get 10% off your first
purchase that's H a wth o R in e CO and
use my code Ric to get 10% off your
purchase Hawthorne dot co and support
Ferber explain comes from manscaped the
best and men's below-the-belt grooming
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels untrimmed
pubes are a thing of the past
whatever the thing was that you held off
doing in november whether it was cutting
or nuttin it's December now so clean it
up boys it's time to gear up and get
yourself a gift of shaving this holiday
season I'm talking about the manscape
perfect package 2.0 holidays sweaters
may be itchy and furry and fun but
they're about the only thing that you'll
wear that's free and fun that's why I
manscaped has redesigned the electric
trimmer their lawnmower 2.0 has
proprietaries advanced skin save
technology so this trimmer won't Nick or
snag your nuts it's also waterproof so
you can use in the shower
the lawnmower 2.0 comes inside their
perfect package 2.0 which makes it be
perfect gift this holiday season it's
literally every
thing you need to keep trimmed to cut
free and smelling nice down there
the manscape perfect package 2.0
includes the crop per server and the
crop Reviver to keep your balls from
sweat and smelling or sticking and these
products smell good a manly scent is
attractive and will help set the mood if
you know what I mean get 20% off and
free shipping with the code Rick's plane
at manscape calm that's 20% off with
Free Shipping at manscaped calm when you
use the code or explained it can be a
bad santa without being a bush five more
minutes and I'm going to get mad my
fault this is happening
how long have you all been eating poop
we have never eaten poop say where did
my family get off to here with us is the
voice of mr. goldenfold himself and he's
a writer on Rick and Morty and a regular
of the harmontown podcast our EP Brandon
Johnson thank you so much for coming on
thank you so much for having me we love
having you here and return to the show
as always this new rock star [ __ ] dragon
yeah me too right that Tommy Bechtel I
like it I like the way it feels
we like the way you feel okay let's talk
about the the big mystery this episode
the talking cat yeah at the end it made
Jerry and Rick vomit which is not a
common thing to see Rick react that way
and I speculated earlier this episode
that it his past is so unspeakably
obscene could be connected to like some
mr. jelly bean stuff that the show wants
to hint at but not like explicitly say
but I'm curious to know you guys thought
it's clearly this is something that the
show left open as a mystery for us to
speculate on what do you guys think they
saw in the cat's backstory I mean I do
kind of feel like it's probably a self
emulation mr. hands a little Christmas
theme yeah I mean if you need something
to make someone vomit as quickly as
possible yeah you got all your uh I'm
trying to think of one other like real
vomit triggers for me you know and baked
beans always make me feel nauseous for
some reason okay that's not code word
for a specific internet oh yeah I look
up baked beans you'll never sleep again
no it's just a can of Bush's baked beans
I don't yeah I think it's gonna have to
be something
unspeakable right like clearly cuz they
don't do like cheap jokes on that show
very much so it wouldn't be like like an
old music video or something like that
it's gonna have to be something truly
horrific they really take you through
the ring around that yeah so like
whatever was watched I think you had a
good story we're talking off-camera
branded about there's a there's a trend
of showing disturbing videos that you
know in the writers room
you can leave blind and you start to
question the people that you work with
after we've shared stuff because part of
it is that you're like I don't know how
you found that but I also don't know how
you suggest another person should see it
yeah how did you find someone eating
their own [ __ ] and decide man this
should be archived like favorites and
the browser of my mind I'm gonna always
have this one ready to go I love hearing
about that with writers rooms how
they'll just try to top each other with
how dark and they can get with the bits
there was like an old ruling in the 90s
they call it like the friends rule with
sitcom writers where you can't sue your
writer or showrunner based off of the
jokes because it's all just like
creative generation and you need to
allow the writers room to go to those
dark places so you know how to rein it
in the episode and you're now in the
room so like how do you think some an
episode like this comes out of
conversation I am no longer in the room
okay I visited I found out that they
didn't have the same snacks the job
right on I was like oh I come up with
jokes at like one o'clock yeah I'm gonna
take a nap and then I get up at like
7:00 and then I'm like hilarious again
at 7:00 to 8:00 but that's not how so I
was and I have left them to do their
tasks which they do beautifully on a
daily basis it was incredible to be in
there and I think all things spawn
episodes so you you can see that they
were sort of on a game of Thrones
Dungeons and Dragons
like wave in order to get to this season
or to give this episode it's also super
crazy because I think Rick and Morty
here's its own voice mhm and wants to
make fun of itself so it's great that
they went after their fanbase right yeah
dragon lovers yeah and now you know that
dragons are [ __ ] right yeah so which is
also their base people who masturbate I
love though there's no standing that
let's be honest we can Morty fans you
probably 10% of you were holding it
right now yeah that's a rule 37 right
there's an existing and there is a very
active community of deviantART there's
that like weird you walk down the wrong
alley at any comic convention and it's
like all the art shifts from like
Superman and the Justice League to like
like Superman in the thrust is like it's
like hey is there ever a character that
you didn't think you could sexualize
well this man's been doing it for 25
years
here's Chewbacca with seven penises like
okay it's very disturbing I think this
episode went after its fans on in every
storyline because I think the cat
storyline also brought up the element of
questioning things too much yeah you're
right thinking it and being kind of a
know-it-all about stuff and like you
know correcting people and how
correction culture just leads to people
being like alright you've absolutely
educated me on this but I don't want to
talk to you anymore so isolate it's like
cool you can tell me in the comments
that I've said five wrong things and
this but I'm gonna be like I don't wanna
hang out with this yeah going through
the comments on Twitter on reddit like
this seems to be polarized to be able to
subsidize it everyone understands that
the show can get this sexual and thus
obscene but it's rattled some people oh
my god the sound the the staff yeah it
just knows a snap you know that's do we
think the show can go too far or is it
just gonna like it might turn off some
people but they can just double down on
their hardcore fan so whatever turn on
them by making increasingly it sexually
explicit jokes like this well I think
that it's more just it's more of a
mirror on what makes people
uncomfortable and like you know like
let's say generalization like sex tends
to
something that makes people
uncomfortable you know to a certain
degree or they're at least private about
so like no matter what we're always
gonna be a little bit like oh wow I
can't believe they did that I keep and I
was like and trust me I know a lot about
sex I've tried it a few times but like
Oh an expert like the staff was like
jiggly I was like but then I like you
know like I can still take it in because
I'm a tough guy but like I feel like
yeah people are always gonna be a little
uncommon but it's more of an eternal
he's a big strong tough big strong man
like listen I drove my car here by
myself what I made for myself today I
dressed myself obviously nobody ever you
put on this well yeah I just think like
it's always kind of just a mirror on
like for whatever reason sex is always
gonna make people uncomfortable to a
certain degree and then you either are
able to push through it and see the
episode or you go kind of blind to it
and then go take to the internet and
comment on it sure yeah
and you'd mention like the whole idea of
eating [ __ ] inst archiving that like mr.
goldenfold we found out in the pickle
rig episode at least going to therapy
for poop eating like as mr. goldenfold
we've had some of the best lines of the
series like what how did you come into
this role in do you have any like
memories of being in the booth my
favorite thing is that you get to when
you're this character you get to make
people stay and say things in bars but
usually you're you're very drunk so at
the first season was great and I'm drunk
and I'm a bar and somebody would you
know I would I would tell because nobody
can recognize me from the show first
thing I do when I get drunk I'm able to
say to people drunkenly you don't sound
like him and and this is an intervention
[Laughter]
I came into it because I got lucky they
didn't I don't think they knew I've told
the story before but I I'll tell the
shortened version I don't think that
they knew I was hardening and I don't
know I didn't know who
was doing this show Rick and Morty like
I followed Justin for ever dan and I are
neighbors drinking buddies and Justin I
have loved since he did this thing for
channel 101 called mr. sprinkles oh yeah
if you guys get a chance to I know you
guys know it but if you in the rest of
the world the universe if you don't know
it it's mr. sprinkles is amazing it
should be its own show and I'd always
wanted to work with dude so when this
came around I was like yeah for sure go
in the booth do it I got a teacher in
mind that I owned a Catholic school
this guy was my teacher and I was like
if I ever get a chance I'm gonna do this
to its voice so I go in I do this dude
he sounds like nobody else and luckily
it worked out it's great and we saw
earlier in the clip when he was the in
the wasp reality as the caterpillar how
much of that was scripted you mentioned
some of that might have been at least
emotionally ad-libbed because I love in
this show in the boot characters will
scream have mental breakdowns and like
it seems so like real and terrifying in
raw like how much that was just your
it's awful because when somebody says
scream you're like ah right but in
somebody's like no scream for real
you'll scream and then you'll see
people's face in the booth like what
have you been right so the last
caterpillar screams are like they were
jari you have been hurt and tortured in
like they're so generous with me and
goldenfold they don't have to write me
into the show that much they don't have
to spend out much time drawing but I
think that I have contributed to the
best of my ability so that I'm trying to
angle like hey man if you guys draw if
you guys write a man I'll try to make
myself as possible and that that
caterpillar thing I don't know that that
was originally in because I saw them
adding it later I'm not quite sure how
that went down but I would walk by it
every day and the artists would show it
to me hmm
and I knew like once I get in the booth
and that thing is actually moving I'm
my throat out trying to break which is
that's what she's I'm gonna blow my
throat out trying to make that thing
sound as good as possible so I was
really like on the plantation so when
you run up the dirt dirtier washer
washer people working on this plantation
there was an HR the only reason it was
bad why every company needs an HR
department because otherwise every
episode devolves into the whole Marxist
thing anyway
well this has been so great I hate to
come off it seems like we're centering
which is out of time it's I haven't made
my argument about the police yet in
coming out of that technical
difficulties they didn't miss anything
anything we're all just a couple years
older internally Brandon thank you so
much for coming on this show it's been
so great chatting with so much we love
hearing your voice in the show we look
forward to hearing it much much much oh
yeah
yep right am in keep writing in mr.
goldenfold it's the best recurring
character and Tommy as always thank you
forever you were here and I thank you so
much for two
to this week's episode we'll be back
next week to break down the mid-season
finale or episode 5 whatever it's gonna
be and we'll also be doing easter-egg
breakdowns of all the energy oak so you
might have missed and make sure to
subscribe to Rick's planed that's our
podcast feed let's help us beat Ellen or
at least the other Rick and Morty after
shows it exists and thank you so much
for joining us and we'll close out with
our favorite joke of this episode you
know who's into dragons Morty nerds that
refuse to admit their Christian
[Music]